he went to welcome to this video playing
Evan box wig and c5 was a good one did
you pre move that possible so probably
especially off a play with c4 I usually
play with me voy now i just have played
chief sweep I I mean I have no idea
about this how do you play this line
yeah I usually play with c4 I have no
idea about this well this is all I'm
pretty decent for black 95 queen bee
seven and I have a hard time Jim I think
I cannot keep the night down and I
cannot keep a piece that I'm looking
exactly one tempo oh yeah queen bee
seven what's the better I think I place
into the moves the whole time but it was
Syria or something okay I know isn't a
slightly better for white bit at least
is completely unfazed just move
move move let's no bullet game okay so
he's attacking f2 I mean he has to do
something I mean yes structure is
basically toast and I've got the a porn
so he has to do something active
otherwise you just gets killed him a5 is
going to play would be five I guess hmm
III take stinks
Knight c3 I can just take a five then
hmm it doesn't really do all that much
yeah nothing happening here early I
guess look hmm I didn't see okay to our
group takes after I'm with him okay
maybe it may be the book any book takes
after you didn't work but it was instead
was scary it looked quite scary
yeah it's tough to improve this position
really looks kind of nice somehow I'd
but improving it is another matter it's
always this pressure and f4 looks like
an extremely weakening move Jim running
out of time a little bit damn his
constant blitzing got in the good spare
time advantage heading for Anastasia's
made Queen h7 how does he prevent that I
don't see how okay checkmate yeah I want
to sign the end of the game how it
sounded amazing like you can spend 20
seconds on the thunders and yet he is
perfectly fine with Queen B 7 maybe he
was probably fine with Queenie 8 as well
it this is the normal way to play it
because I cannot I now cannot maintain
the night on dd5 you know I have to
accept that he takes and there's a pawn
on d5 at the end which gives us white
absolutely nothing I'd rather be black
let's say for example conch of you take
is a three words okay let's do a three
okay he takes it and this position is
just very okay for black hair black is
probably easier to play I don't think I
should use necessarily but it's very
fine for black and this problem on defy
the soft now 90 m at least I get a
little bit of control I mean maybe it's
a slight edge
I wasn't really spending any time I also
played quite quickly that I didn't want
to go into into huge time pressure you
know did you did he have look f2 eif the
tilted too sir I overlooked a tactic
it's probably not fatal but this and
this 93 and kind of interesting he still
as extremely big back rank ok the engine
says equal math would have been a
crapshoot anything can happen them yeah
so here yeah fo i think was was good
because here after the capture he has
these coordination issues the kid i was
a typically quick move that loads
instantly simply simply didn't think in
a way look the eight still okay after
this it's gone the hook is attacked and
I'm threatening the maid okay so he got
Anastasia's made on the water pretty
nice one ok guys thanks for watching